before video begins
g-fuel bogo sale bogo you buy one you
get one which means
you buy one and then you get one so if
you buy one you get one do you get it
do you understand
just use the link in the description you
don't have to add any codes this time
around so you just add two tubs and one
of them
automatically
for free you get one
it works with this
the greatest flavors of all time and
it's a great way to stock up stock up
from some g fuel they also have pink
lemonade for you pink lemonade drinkers
and stoic flavors
to celebrate the absolute stoic purchase
of buy one get one
but it's a great way to try out new
flavors stock up with some g fuel
definitely take advantage of this offer
it's probably the the best ones they get
you you guys know i love g fuel with all
my heart and passion it's a great energy
drink
that just makes you feel good
energy drink gang g fuel gang floor gang
best drink on the market gang
tastes so good in my mouth gang
on with video already felix gang yeah
all right thanks for uh thanks for thank
see you in the end see in the video
today we're lining up by birds of the
bees
what
where's the bees
why what is that ken what is that can
you tell me well you see
the birds and the bees
is
birds
what people say when they're talking
about
uh
what is
we don't have birds and bees in sweden
i'm trying to think of what we say
because i have a whole holiday that
celebrates fertility when you talk oh
come on come on it's still my favorite
time of summer everybody around the big
sack in the sky and sings the frog song
i can't believe they turned our beloved
midsummer into a horror film uh did they
yeah if people talk about cultural
appropriation yeah well thank jesus
thanks for turning ours into a [ __ ]
nightmare crap what is like a cult or
something
it's not
we just clipped them to death
we just clubbed them
and dragged them behind the husqvarna
yeah yeah yeah no that movie is actually
100 accurate anyway wait
i gotta see what the swedish version is
is there one i think what i was told was
the stork oh the stroke that drops the
babies off of that yeah yeah that's what
i think i read about that in a magazine
and i'm like
guess that makes sense yeah yeah just
like yoshi's island yeah they dropped
the baby mario's off yeah
yeah
what were some misconceptions you had
about the birds and the beasts come on
misconceptions that i had yeah because i
had none i knew it i knew it all
yeah i i didn't
let me think
i don't know my parents were very
straight up about it like whenever all
right yeah
yeah cause i was like how are babies
made and they were like well you
put your thing in this thing and then
you know
that's how babies were made and i was
like oh
um
they didn't make up some story or
anything they were just like this is how
it happens and i was very confused
because i was like
why would you do that
why don't you just give me the historic
version
god dad
aren't you happier in retrospect that
that's what you got i mean of course the
misconceptions of how it all actually
goes down and what goes into it you know
when you're you're using you're like why
would you do that but i asked my parents
like why and they're like yo you
understand when you're older and i was
like oh okay
that's good i like that you'll
understand later bro just stop yeah once
you have what you go through all that
then you'll know i was so sure
that babe baby come from poopoo
yeah but they're for the longest time
i'm still not sure
i think every kid goes to that really
because yeah things exit that's where
yeah it makes sense it makes more sense
we even make a joke around our house
like your mom's gonna poop out a baby
and they're like oh you're gonna poop
out a baby you know
it continues a tradition of life
nice
oh i'm curious to see how these parents
will handle it so let's uh what [ __ ]
there i'm just looking at this the
screen here this kid looks like he's
like five or six i think he's a little
young to be having this talk right um
what's the appropriate age ken i was
like nine or ten yeah that seems more
yeah
well i was like five because that's when
i got puberty yeah right right
okay
my mustache came at five and a half
well it's a shame that
i can't make fun of your beard you can
grow a beard nevermind yes
most people i know can't grow beards
very well oh yeah you're still working
on that beard what i'm saying is this
video if they're explaining to this kid
is this kid interested in knowing did he
ask or are they right
it's really weird if the child doesn't
ask the only way i see this appropriate
is
all right let's see what they say we're
here today
uh my video
we're gonna talk about
where babies come from
do you know
anything about intercourse
[Music]
wow oh that is weird
that is weird
it's a very weird question to ask oh
that is what do you think about these
things what if she said yes
that's also kind of putting the child at
the spot like what
what do you know about sex huh
you know what i mean
yeah
yeah what do you know about this yeah
what do you know about this huh
bruh that's so weird so that guy's hat
so um today we're going to talk about
how babies are made
you know they tell us in school school
system here in sweden relieve the the
pain for parents to do this i was
thinking about that just now like
getting that a weird thing that the
that it's put on schools to educate your
children about this stuff
no parents are too uncomfortable to talk
to their kids about it
wouldn't school be better
think about think about every parent i'm
sure you as a parent is better but think
about every parent ken yeah you're right
yeah
you really are
he can't trust all his parents out there
no
to do this yeah yeah
would you like to know how babies are
made made of water humans are in the
bottle
you miss a made of water he's right
that's right that's right he doesn't
have any interest in you like telling
him telling him anything else
okay but where does water come from
where did they go with it i knew it
that's true oh god
i thought it was because of god that
sent us down into your stomach to be
born to be born sperm egg
so
that's right
god sends the babies down into the
stomach
and she definitely didn't cheat on
anyone
[Laughter]
what do you mean sperm a collide where
did you learn that from
why
i can't i can't hear children ken can
you hear your children do you understand
your children because whenever a child
speaks to me i'm like i don't understand
a single word yeah yeah i understand you
know okay what does this say
what does it say what does it say then
what does it say all right go ahead play
let's see
sperm egg collide bella
what the [ __ ] was that yeah sperm egg
clod blah
the last is not a word he just goes
below
they can't just make up words
of course they get their kids they can
make a man again god damn
he's educated he already knows he knows
about the sperm and egg ba-bam
egg blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah
i think that means that he doesn't want
he need he doesn't need to know more
than that right yeah he's like blah blah
blah everything else
where did you learn that from nick
duh who's nick
my brother
hey what did he tell you
who's nick you have a brother
brother am i your dad hang on a minute
hold on a second is this jerry springer
am i the father are you the father
what the [ __ ] is happening
dad's learning how they work right now
what makes me a man and what makes mom a
woman
oh god
careful careful lady you're gonna get
canceled in 10 years
yeah be real careful no no
you think a gender is divided by trouble
though
you know that me and mama are girls
yes
do you know
is there a specific body part that you
know of the place
ew
hell
right really yeah grilling their kids do
you know
do you know about my vagina do you know
about my my genitalia no no do you know
like if my mom talked to me like that
mom get that
i need therapy what why would you do
this to a child right i want to think
about your part yeah
no thank you
yeah i want you to think about my vagina
right now this is so weird
hey hey son
you know what we got
think about it think about what i got
down there
think about it you know do you know what
i have you know you know what we got you
know son hey you may think this looks
shriveled up and weird and
disproportionate but sometimes a little
cold outside you know
but then we will share the same thing
[Laughter]
we are good at this we're way better
equipped for this [ __ ]
i mean it's i think the best way to do
it is just to say the penis goes in the
vagina and then that's how babies are
made the rest of the part will fill
itself in as yeah they'll they'll figure
out the race yeah yeah yeah yeah you
have to get graphic with it because
it'll be like wait what happens to me
whenever i do this yeah what
i'm scared mom don't worry it's fine
miracle life work on the miracle of life
all the vangina right the vangina
you know it's called the vagina don't
call me out for not knowing how to say
vagina oh yeah he loves to be part of
this
oh no why would you put this image in my
retina mom
yeah
yeah maybe they're not ready for this
conversation if that's how they react
just a thought ah
yeah
okay how do you pronounce it did i say
it's called vagina vengeance
it's a diet a giant
vagina
it just makes more sense
it makes me more sense
i'm not convinced
like i'm pretty sure
yeah what do you know man
i was going to go
now i was going to i was about to call
for one of my kids
bring layla here because i'm pretty sure
she knows where baby's coming because
she'll tell me oh yeah yeah you're going
to tell me
yeah i don't want to i want to put her
on the spot i'm not going to do that no
don't do that that would be funny though
does it come through the bottom
hell yeah
hi
so i felt quite embarrassed for thinking
this but i guess it's not that weird
i'll tell you it's normal because it's
yeah it's it's like the easy way to like
say where do babies come from oh you
know
poop it out just poop it out
mary's pretty straight up she's like it
comes out of the vagina you know she's
just
yeah what's so wrong about the vagina
huh yeah yeah nothing nothing
what
we're not sure we're not trying to have
this like conversation to our kids don't
understand anything we're just kind of
telling them
about their body parts in
like like where do babies come from the
vagina like that not like anything more
than hey
think about mine as they grow up they
just kind of understand it right yeah
just like i did that way i have to have
awkward conversations like this stop
dropping your god dang knife i'll leave
the keyboard man
i thought you're good at that
sorry
sorry i had to
go dad on there for a minute
i can do whatever i want i'm an adult
not in my house you can't i want to see
what they're drawing here i want to see
this drawing
what are they drawing
don't say that again okay one more love
melody
no more love
i don't understand why they gotta force
the child to know something they don't
want to know they're trying to make a
video man you gotta you gotta this is
weird gonna go for it i get yeah it's
pretty weird it's probably why the video
is only four minutes long
that's a good point actually they're
usually way longer
when
two
adults want to have a child
they have to
work together
yeah work together yeah
love all right um going to use another
word
mommy and daddy hang out
if we hang out
later on the child will be traumatized
thinking
wait i'm hanging out right now oh god
am i making my bridges
what am i dead
i'm going to get pregnant no
[Laughter]
i have a baby i'm not oh my god
[Music]
the commitment the mom provides egg and
um and the diet provides a sperm hell oh
yeah this child knows
there we go yeah they're just being very
scientific about it it kind of yeah it
kind of makes sense to go scientific
about it right because you don't
technically need to know like the whole
body part the shim debacle
yeah i think so sit all that fills
itself in as yeah
oh
okay
where does it come out
do you know what it comes out
the sperm comes out of your penis
and when he releases
oh
dude having this conversation with my
mom no thank you okay
i'd rather not
they're gonna go to the bathroom just
like stand there look at themselves yeah
i would oh god is it bad like is there
is this pretty conceived thing in my
brain that i shouldn't be talking with
my parents about this stuff and that's
like unhealthy or something or is it
just weird it's pretty normal yeah it's
the way it's explained like feels until
if it's the scientific way then you'll
be okay talking with your parents about
it okay yeah yeah yeah but if they
they're talking about it in the you
don't want to think of your parents as
being romantic no it's not you you don't
want to think about that
so they explain it in that way then
there's like
please no
i told you one game but my parents did
right they did the best thing and i'm
forever grateful for it they gave me a
book that said what all this [ __ ] meant
like all those terms all of it and i
just felt like i had unlocked like this
forbidden knowledge this were the
ancient tones of truth basically i was
like holy [ __ ] i know it all
and uh it was great because then other
kids would be like hey
do you know what this means i'm like
yeah you're [ __ ] right i knew
dude i've seen the diagram i'm seeing
that thing looks crazy i've seen all the
waves
yeah i think that's the best way yeah i
guess yeah if you just hit here go read
this yeah any questions ask your mom
exactly that's pretty good
i'll never forget my best friend whose
dad took him out on a boat that just
seems like nightmare scenario to me
rowing out on a [ __ ] boat and then
going hey
we're gonna have a talk
you can literally not escape from me and
we're gonna talk about
so awful
oh man
but i do think it's an important thing
to discuss though because it seems like
when these things sex become like a
taboo for people they in their teenage
years they kind of just like explore it
maybe more than what is healthy you know
what i mean yeah yeah
i feel like it's also harder to explain
this to
your your son as well
yeah yeah
yeah yeah i don't look forward to that i
don't remember you can anyway that's
what when they're having sex when
they're making love
that
makes
a baby i don't like that okay
i don't like uh
did she say that why'd i say that i
don't like that oh man your dad comes at
your dad's stuff and it comes in your
mom's stuff and he's like
take the parents out of it
when a boy does this yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's weird visualizing the
parents yeah yeah yeah you don't need to
be part of this stage play you perv you
weirdo you're not that important
sometimes it can make a baby
maybe i did not know you did not know
that yeah
this kid seems more the appropriate age
here yeah it's a bit older yeah the
other kids
the penis get to which
the vagina
ah this is so funny to him
oh that is so funny isn't it that's
hilarious pinnacle of comedy right there
this man will become fart and poop joe
kind of man
[Laughter]
so get this cock's not ready
he'll just stand up comedy guys get this
the funniest [ __ ] oh man
is it medically
it's like mommy's a nurse i don't know
what mommy does right
that's so fed up how do you give the
sperm to mommy
again you know to get yourself like get
yourself out of this picture but you
could just say how that's a sperm get
into the egg
we're just such better parents can yeah
we really are yeah just take it just
take that take ourselves out of it
[Applause]
so mommy and daddy got together and we
took off all our clothes
and we got inside the blankets so we
were really warm
and then mommy and daddy did a special
dance and there you looks special dance
oh my god
i don't think they need to say that hey
they're just dawning on me like this is
the story it's so weird
this is the worst story it takes out any
of what actually happens and then
yeah and here i am i'm bored wow
oh god yeah it's pretty terrible b minus
c minor
is
really
really no good if you took all your
clothes off you see this pocket yeah
okay
the pocket oh god what are you what is
he doing
my pockets are vaginas is that what he's
about to say
see i stick my thing oh god no
is the vagina
okay and in order to have a child
daddy has to put
his
penis in the pocket
this this is the worst analogy
i have ever heard
she's like
she's gonna think that you're pregnant
by putting penis in his people's pocket
or some [ __ ] what is this
she has a vagina you don't need him to
talk about some pocket analogy
what the [ __ ]
she's like
yeah
goes into the vagina go ahead
[Music]
cause we're just [ __ ] you know why
not
oh
this is uncomfortable
yes yes sorry yeah
why why this is child torture
and i'm saying torturing me dude yeah
why is you do anything to a child and
they say was that painful and they say
yes is is bad
unless you tell them this
huh
why is it okay i'm very upset for these
children these poor children didn't
deserve individual videos i'm good i'm
good thank you all right cool now we
know what not to do thank you ken
appreciate your insight as well i've
learned a lot i've learned a lot of this
video this is very educational i think
i'm prepared for uh the birds and the
bees talk with my own kids but of course
i won't have to have the talk with them
because we're going to raise them with
the knowledge of how
our bodies work because they're our
bodies and it's not some secret
knowledge that needs to be locked away
until they're like old enough to scar
them forever
it is a balance it's a balance
i don't know i just felt like i needed
to contribute or something
he's gonna set those up in there i do
think it's a lot harder to explain to
your like to little boys though because
like that part of their body hasn't
changed like the girls
it stuff's gotta change but the basics
are already kind of there right yeah the
boy's gotta do this whole different
thing and then some stuff comes at some
stuff and he's gonna be like oh my god
what
what's gonna happen to me hang on a
second what
you're the one who has to do it though
i'd rather hear from my dad than my mom
yeah yeah
that's what i'm saying i think for that
for the little boys
you put the penis the vagina and that's
what happens and then they're like well
how they're like well you're gonna
understand one day because that's pretty
much what you're gonna be doing with all
your free time
that's right just replace your hand i
want to talk about in the video
[Applause]
stop
it's today's birthday happy birthday
check out 10 channel and
check out me as well subscribe don't
check out cut
you thought it was gay
but true relevance never really died
welcome to the first undead game use any
item in your inventory and make memes
inside tuber simulator add some of our
patented stickers in there stickers are
emotions memes our emotions express your
emotions with me
share them for likes share them for love
get up for free
and who knows
maybe i'll review your memes the
greatest honor of all
time full circle baby download it make a
meme
we need subtitles on this